So, our students have a facility with digital technology.
And it's right and proper, therefore that we should build them into the heart of education.
But it's also important we do it because the tools themselves...
...are creating cultural change and possibilities which are really quite new.
Our students are connected not just with the people in the room around them...
...but with literally anybody on the planet they care to be connected to.
And that's an entirely new cultural proposition, I think, and it changes the game.
And my argument is that one of the reasons we have to transform education and we already do,...
...is because the technologies have changed the whole context of education.
But there are also among the ways in which the transformation itself will take place.
So this shift, to me, is much more than a shift in the way we do art...
...or the way we do design, although that's certainly the case.
These tools are extraordinary there.
They affect the way we think in all disciplines.
They affect the way we think of disciplines.
They affect the way disciplines interact.
So these new tools seem to me, to be providing opportunities in the palette of possibilities...
...which should be available to every single student, not just to a few.